what is our imagery of cities when we
imagine cities we often imagine it to be
something like this but what if what
you're looking at is just half a picture
but there is a city within this city
this part of the city is often seen as
slums squatters informal and people
living here are called illegal informal
criminals beneficiary supplicants etc
but in reality these are poor people
with no choices
poverty is a wicious cycle if born poor
it can take three or more generations to
escape one many are forced in this cycle
without choices to live on pavements
along train tracks in dumping grounds
along rivers swamps and many such
unlivable spaces without clean water
toilets or housing but these places are
not unfamiliar to me because since the
age of 6 I accompanied my father a
doctor who treated patients in the slums
of Bombay growing up I would help him
carry his bag of medicines after school
lessons I loved doing that
wanting to do something about these
habitats I did has decided to become an
architect but quite early on I realized
that the beauty of architecture was only
for the rich so I decided to do urban
planning and joined an NGO in India that
works with the urban poor who organized
themselves to access basic services such
as water sanitation and housing for poor
living in cities now I spent 10 years of
my life in professional education in
learning and then five years in
unlearning it because I realized that
all my training in architecture design
and planning failed ground Riya
Letty's and this is where I learned the
power of choice I unlearned many things
but there are two myths about the poor
that I would like to share that we live
with the first myth is a perception that
migration of poor people into cities is
a problem
is migration really a choice
my mentor Sheela Patel asked to those
who think this off as a problem go ask
your grandfather where he came from
she says so what do poor people do when
they migrate in cities let me share an
example this is the Mumbai International
Airport all that you see in blue are
large informal settlements around it
close to 75,000 people live here so who
are these people that work silently in
hotels restaurants as labourers
babysitter's house helps and countless
other jobs that we need cities to
function without a glitch and where do
they live
in most cities they live in slums so let
us think again do we want poor people to
stop migrating in our cities
what if they had a choice of not to the
second myth is a is that is my personal
experience is this attitude that we
professionals know better
we professionals love to make choices
for others especially for the poor let
me share an experience in a workshop
that looked at designing 250 new houses
for poor families from Aslam nearby
there were different building materials
that were presented ranging from paper
mash cardboard honeycomb etc simply
because they were affordable but there
was this one idea that was of shipping
containers now we immediately approved
of it because we thought it was
sustainable scalable affordable but
during this presentation a lady from the
slum humbly spoke up and she asked the
presenter
would you choose to live in that if not
then why did you think we would now this
was a personal unlearning moment for me
where I realized that poverty only
changes affordability it does not change
aspirations now poor people have lived
in temporary structures all their life
they go from wall to wall moving from
bricks to tin they move from building
from bamboo tarpaulin sheets plastic to
cardboard to tin to bricks and cement
just like the way we do so somewhere
here we were forcing our choices on them
so should we force our choices on them
or should we broaden their choices now
what if the opportunity to choose was
given to people these are women who
lived on the pavements of a neighborhood
in Mumbai
now they faced constant evictions and in
response to it they organized a women's
network called mellimelon not only did
they fought against evictions with those
in power saved money and bought land but
they also designed and helped construct
their own houses well these were
illiterate women so how did they do that
they used floor mats and saris to
understand measurements a sari is four
meters in length and 1.5 meters in width
they use these simple day-to-day items
to demonstrate house models and even
they made three options to choose from
and invited all their fellow residents
to come and have a look and everybody
loved this option that had a loft in it
simply because of the two things one is
it accommodated larger families to sleep
in and two it allowed home-based work
such as bangle making jewelry designing
embroidery stitching packaging items etc
now they also decided to not have a
toilet inside but instead have it
outside in the corridors simply because
it gave them more space and it was
cheaper now professionals could have
never thought of something like that
a formal design would have necessary to
have a toilet in sight now these are
smaller examples let me share some
larger contexts 881 million people
that's about one sixth of this world as
we talk here are living in slums and
informal settlements almost every city
in the global South has large slums in
the size of townships Kibera in Nairobi
Dharavi in Mumbai kaliesha in South
Africa just a few now initially they
were all on waste and abandoned lands
that cities were never interested in as
cities grew poor people started building
on these lands and bought value to this
over time and today these lands have
become real estate hotspots that
everybody wants a piece of it so what
does cities and those in power choose to
deal with them they demolish them and
evict them and move them away from their
cities and economies in order to build a
new infrastructure they move them into
vertical housing which in reality looks
like this now when built in high
densities they lack natural light and
ventilation and often leads to unhealthy
conditions now on one hand who are
people are not involved in the
participation of design and there is
poor quality of construction and on the
other hand they do not understand how to
do maintenance you know keeping bills
keeping records forming societies this
is all very difficult for them and being
forced to move into this formal society
they end up looking like this in a few
years because formalization is not a
product it's a process moving from
informal to formal for poor people is a
journey it takes time to accept and
adapt and when that choice is not given
it becomes like this which I'm afraid in
future these would become
the slumps now instead of doing this
what if we accommodated poor people and
gave them a choice to be a part of our
cities and develop them where they are
giving them basic services like in this
picture now what happens if cities and
governments could work together
if governments acknowledge four people
and they could build it together
this is mukuru it's a large informal
settlement in Nairobi it's one of the
largest settlements in Africa it's home
to 300,000 people living over 650 acres
of land to help us understand that scale
it's like squeezing the population of
Pittsburgh in the New York Central Park
that's mukuru so to give us a glimpse
this is the condition of housing and
this is what it is in between them so
what is life in Makura like just talking
briefly 550 people use one single water
tap and pay nine times more than what
anybody else in the city could pay
simply because there is no water
infrastructure and water result many
come back from work to find out that
their houses do not exist because there
is either been bulldozed or they've been
burnt down so tired of the situation a
local slum dwellers Federation called
Mangano decided to do something about it
in four years
they organized 20,000 residents to
collect data map structures and put it
together and the plan was very simple
they only needed four things they wanted
clean water toilets decent roads and
most importantly not to be wicked
so they presented this with a government
of Nairobi and for the first time in
history ever a city has agreed to do it
the city of Nairobi the government of
Kenya declared mukuru to be a special
planning area which means that people
could come up with their own
plan people could decide to come up with
their own norms and standards because
the standards that work for the former
citizens do not work in informal
settings so what does that mean to give
us an instance if these are roads in
mukuru you can see that there are houses
along both sides of the road now in
order to bring in a city bus as for the
standards planners would have gone for a
luxurious 25 metre wide road now that
would mean displacing 20% of the
structures as lots of people so instead
of doing that we came up with a 12 metre
wide road which had the structures in
fact and bought the city bus without
compromising on my services on another
instance let's talk about community
toilets you know in high-density areas
where there is no scope for individual
toilets like the public toilets that we
have here so we would go for a male
section and a female section but imagine
this situation in the morning rush hours
to the toilet when everybody is an
intense pressure to relieve themselves
and if you are standing in a queue of 50
people and there is a child standing
behind an adult who wins children end up
squatting outside and that's why women
decided to come up with a separate
squatting area for children now who
could have thought of something like
that the idea here is that when poor
people choose they choose better they
choose what works for them so choice is
everything and power decides choice and
we need those in power
politicians leaders governments
architects planners institutions
researchers and all of us in our
everyday lives to respect choices
instead of choosing what is right for
people for the poor let's acknowledge
and empower their choices and that is
how we can build better an inclusive
cities for tomorrow
completing the imagery of cities built
by the choices of its own people thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]